hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video ich hoffe natürlich
jedes gut wir haben heute mal wieder was
besonders vor ich habe das sogar recht
oft gerät also wirklich diese youtuber
die man sagen viele von euch haben mich
gefragt der nach deswegen also manche
habe ich das auch schon mal gemacht aber
diesmal haben es wirklich viele
geschrieben warum ich denn noch nie so
einen klamotten restposten bestellt habe
also halt mal waren gute klamotten oder
wissen wir halt noch nicht aber es gibt
viele angebote ich habe ja auch
mittlerweile gute kontakte in der
branche muss man sagen er ist es so
windig heute und mein nachbar der hat da
oben irgendwelche pflanzen stehen die
kleinen die ganze zeit ging es geländer
auf jeden fall habe ich bestellt das ist
jetzt nichts negatives gewesen für knapp
200 euro mit versand seeger roundabout
200 euro 35 restposten adidas ich
wünsche euch hier einen nike reebok
alles mögliche kann da drin sein ich
glaube halt alles außer schulen also zum
anziehen für damen herren jr ward muss
ich sagen es für mich auch neuland ja
ich bin ja auch kein fashion youtuber
aber trotzdem so was habe ich auf
youtube eigentlich noch nie gesehen so
ein paket deswegen zu machen weil ich
muss auch ganz ehrlich sagen ich kann
mir schon vorstellen dass der gute
sachen drin sind theorie auch wegen dem
messer wieder ne also ohne witz das ist
das letzte mal dass ich jetzt hier so
ein amateur messe habe ich bestelle mir
gleich direkt ein besseres geht ja
eigentlich nicht auf dauer ich will ja
auch wahr
ich will ja auch irgendwann mal
professioneller unterwegs sein auf jeden
fall denke schon dass sind das wirklich
sport und das alles ich dachte dass wir
momentan kurz okay wir haben hier
wirklich sportartikel das wusste ich gar
nicht ich dachte eigentlich dass es auf
streetwear streetwear ich dachte
eigentlich dass ist auch streetworker
street straßenklamotten die man auf der
straße auftragen kann habe ich gedacht
aber im wahrscheinlich hier ist alles
mögliche drin gehe ich mal von aus pro
teil habe ich so im schnitt dann circa
fünf euro bezahlt und ich weiß nicht ob
man das für mehr verkaufen können
wir werden sehen hier ist noch die
richtung wahrscheinlich bei oder also
das ganze natürlich sportmarken posten
mix ich muss halt sagen dass ich mich ja
mal direkt man basketball trikot von
frankreich was ich erst mal an sich sei
schon feiern
ist das die sachen alle noch eingepackt
sind hier haben war ich werde es auf
jeden fall auch wieder so machen dass
ich euch versuche die preise mit
einzublenden was das denn sonst kostet
weil wie gesagt ihr könnt davon ausgehen
ich hab halt im schnitt fünf euro
bezahlt pro teil finde ich an sich
sollte das ganz gut sind so was kostet
doch schon bestimmt die eigentlich aber
gut ist wahrscheinlich auch alles aus
lauf war ich bin noch wirklich los was
so klamotten hat dann haben wir hier
auch adidas hosen schon mal so eine ganz
normale sporthose ist an sich schon
hässlich eine in diesem farbton aber
früher hätte ich damit ich kann auch
jetzt damit viel anfangen weil ich habe
nicht mehr so viele sportarten ich mache
ja schon auch manchmal sport ich hätte
aber mehr gefeiert wenn da wirklich
sachen drin sind zum anziehen sachen mit
denen rausgehen kann es nicht nur zum
sport auch womit du in die schule gehen
kannst und so weiter hier haben wir noch
ist das denn ein trikot von olympiakos
olympiakos piräus
walter das muss ja an sich auch original
sein oder das ist größte wir machen das
mal auch leute ihr wisst ja an sich ich
bin schon ein großer fußballfan schweiz
nicht von piräus aber trotzdem so ein
originales trikot von denen an die
griechen und guck mal und wir haben hier
wirklich ein originales trikot ist das
ist auf jeden fall okay gut das ganze
haben wir in drei verschiedenen größen
jetzt haben wir hier noch auch nochmal
zwei hosen muss ich auch sagen an sich
finde ich die nicht schön aber adidas
sporthose legen wir mal hier zu und
jetzt wird es ein bisschen interessanter
das haben wir hier seien politik das
hier wärst du das erste teil wo ich mir
auch vorstellen könnte das selber privat
einfach so zu tragen das ist das denn
ist das eine hose ach das ist ja einfach
einfach mal ja ich kann mir vorstellen
dass selber privat zu tragen einfach
einen dummy sport kleid
wenn wir das aber ganz schön groß gut
dass da irgendwie so aus als wäre es ein
pulli lege ich auch mal dahin und ganz
wichtig zu sagen die preise die ihr dann
manchmal stehen das sind die günstigsten
preise die ich finde wenn ich diese
sachen im internet google ja natürlich
musste auch für alles einen abnehmer
finden und es wird schon sinn haben
warum das alles so günstig weg geht hier
haben wir eine hose ach guck mal denke
mal dass es auch nicht es kann auch für
die von adidas nie hat man eine denn im
cargo in der größe 28 ihr stets daran
von der marke reebok chillige hose
eigentlich fühlt sich ganz gut dann
stinkt bisschen ja jetzt aber mal wieder
was für mich weit blank das jersey das
ist wieder das ist glaube ich schon
wieder weit für frauen oder komm mal
wieder so ein langes ringen diesmal in
der farbe war hebt denke ich auch fit
ich muss gleich mal googeln was man für
solche sachen noch oder wie toll die mal
waren dann haben wir noch eine hose
wieder zweimal dieses jersey was wir
eben schon hatte nach sodass hier ist
die gleiche rose in größe 29 ok und das
hier ist jetzt ein normales t shirt von
adidas also kein sport shirt schaue ich
mir mal vorsichtig anleger das feierlich
das behalte ich wohl dmo stopp von 1
jetzt hab ich's zerstört es ist wieder
für frauen ach so
die sind in der größe 3 xl leicht liegt
daran dass die keiner haben will ja gut
das ist auch schon groß aber so auch was
heißt mäßig wieso nicht mädels tragen
doch heutzutage so was das sieht auch
heiß aus wenn man so ein schönes adidas
jersey oversized trägt in rot weil ich
dachte gerade steht ich dachte gerade
wirklich hier steht philipp plein
drunter aber nein das steht made in
philippinen haben wir noch ein weiteres
adidas trikot in der farbe blau größe l
will ich das habe ich dann hier noch mal
noch mal hier ein bisschen anders aber
auch in größe l gut das war mir auch
vorher klar dass wir schon auch sachen
natürlich in mehrfacher ausführung haben
und nicht komplett verschiedene sachen
die haben wir dann noch drei weitere
male dieses rote adidas jersey hier noch
eine rose hier nochmal
ja und dann hier noch zweimal das in
blau okay das war's dann leider auch
schon
ich weiß gar nicht also kann sein dass
ich jetzt aufgehört habe ich immer den
preis einzeln deswegen würde ich hier
nochmal den gesamtpreis ein wenn ich
schaue dass jetzt auch direkt manna und
dann werde ich mal so mein fazit dazu
sagen ob sich sowas lohnen kann so leute
ich habe jetzt mal alle produkte im
internet zusammen gesucht das ganze
zusammengerechnet und wir kommen mit
allen sachen wenn ich die für die preise
verkaufen würde wie es im internet steht
auf 419 euro 97 also hört sich erst mal
viel an
das ding ist vieles von den sachen ist
von 2017
vieles hat auch übergröße also drei xl
zum teil was halt viel zu groß ist
weswegen ich auch nicht versuchen werde
viel davon zu verkaufen
leute das geht ich hab ich mal kurz in
schale geschmissen
sieht doch gut aus oder also zu sport
machen wieso nicht ich zwar noch mal
kurz die andere hohl sein also diese
kabellose mal gucken ob die besteht also
dieses oben vielleicht ein bisschen eng
aber trotzdem so kann man noch im laufen
ich muss sagen ich muss mal schauen was
ich mit den sachen mache ich gehe davon
aus dass ich vieles davon einfach
spenden werde weil ich glaube nicht dass
ich das alles weg kriegen trotzdem werde
ich ein bisschen davon auch einfach mal
auf meinen restkosten scharf stellen
lucky domaene.de könnte ja gerne
vorbeischauen wenn ihr bock habt auch
halten also ich will damit jetzt kein
geld verdient nur das ist halt weg kommt
weil ich weiß nicht vielleicht kann er
gegen jemand von euch da draußen was
gebraucht
trotzdem ich glaube die hose behalte ich
hier von wald ich auch was und dann hat
sich ein bisschen auch für mich gelohnt
das kann man ja schon sagen ganz
schlecht was ja nicht ich bin mir sicher
dass ich das meiste einfach spenden
werde weil ich habe hier auf jeden fall
genug adressen wo ich manchmal meine
alten klamotten auch hin spende das ist
ja auch schon eine coole sache ich muss
aber sagen dieses klamotten restposten
projekt ist für mich ein bisschen
gescheitert zumindest dort wo ich
bestellt hat wenn ihr noch irgendwie
einen besseren link habt ein besseres
angebot schickt mir das super gerne zu
gerne bei instagram und ja das war es
eigentlich hoffe es hat euch trotzdem
gefallen
wir sehen uns immer morgen schon wieder
gibt's neues video abonniert sehr gern
den kanal sechs videos ab jetzt komme
nicht wieder viele videos das war's haut
rein
[Musik]